Ray have you been bipped in the bay yet
I've been a lot of things in the bay
um I mean that means somebody someone
cracked your window and took something
out of your car because you know that's
like right now the the bipping capital
of the world is the Bay Area yeah so
it's getting a lot of things in the bay
but I can truly say that I haven't been
gotta knock on wood there yeah I mean
God is good you know I barely Drive
anymore right so I might hop out of an
Uber have you been I might catch the
public transit there you know no not not
oh yeah most definitely I got my whole
whip stalling and then they stumped it
out oh man they just like stripped it
maybe that's a chunk it out
he found me like bipped
I always I do feel like it'd be a good
YouTube channel to like just roll into
like downtown San Francisco with a
rental and have like a clown hidden in
the trunk right so you park and you know
you're about to get bipped how do you
know you're gonna get bit because they
know what the rentals look like so you
just you know you have a couple white
people park the car look like tourists
within like 10 minutes their cars
getting bipped and then they go to open
the trunk and a clown jumps out so so
what you're saying to me is that there's
a very high percentage that when you
park yeah high percentage that when you
park you somebody's gonna just break
your window and and take what though
anything any and everything so right now
like so like you know John Carson who's
uh shout out to John's Steven Tyler dog
shot I love him uh John will leave his
windows rolled down
and like yo go ahead take a peek just
don't break my window a lot of people do
that like literally I have nothing in
the car just go ahead take a look get in
look around so you it's safe to say that
and I don't I don't promote this brand
I'm just I just know the commercial but
safe like repairs yeah you're gonna need
a lot of that stay all the way up
probably in there if you got a window
repair service I mean the greatest
repair service of all time they get it
done same day yo they've been thinking
they bit Brian Sampson a lot like last
month he was pumping gas by the Oakland
Airport and his dumb ass was on the
phone probably [__] talking about
food you know what I mean like he likes
and he wasn't even paying attention
and they popped his trunk and jacked all
his luggage by the time he turned around
and looked they were already running
into a car and he can you imagine Brian
trying to pull the pump out of the thing
and then chase people in Oakland that's
some Coming to America [__] let me tell
you like this when me and Ray Jess was
in Oakley and I told the uh the the
promoter I'm like yo we need two
security guards to watch the cars if we
pull up we're gonna pull up right in the
front we need two security guards to
watch the cars and that's exactly what
they did so you just got to kind of move
me you got to know what you're doing you
gotta move kind of presidential out
there I was out there with Cassie one
day me and you cash in sweet little cash
she bit her car took her laptop and
everything Cassie the singer yeah so
when you when you park she had some
great leaked photos
all-time great leaks she's got they
bipped her they took her laptop and
everything when we park in the bank I
have a security guard stand by us [__]
if you want to be super game tight Jesus
or this Uber [__] it I mean I know that
you didn't tell me about it because I
had the security guards at the car you
had it handled well look for all the
bippers out there in the bay we'll be
out there this weekend and
um yeah there's gonna be a bull riding
contest and what I want to tell all the
bippers is that I I listen I respect
what y'all do when I don't just respect
my [__]
Mr Fab has got like like Mr fabus said
no one's above the bip he's been bipped
twice I think six months he might not
have had the security guards at his at
his time but no one's above the bip no
well then maybe when we park we gonna
bounce out and then we gonna go just
take your [__] with you take the car
around the car you can't leave anything
in the car
no no value you know what you could do
ray to get raycon out in the street a
little you leave some raycon products in
the car dope let them take it and feed
it to the streets not ask but not that's
real baby what that's pimping go ahead
and pimping can we look at the trademark
on bipping I like that let's try to see
what's up with that
um so yeah
sounds good I like it I like the word I
like it I think I think Berner is
working on a movie called bippin that's
what's up that's what's a big burn man
shout out yeah big shout out big big
shout out Ray you've obviously been
killing it on the just entrepreneurial
side
um you sold your scoot company yes uh
yeah I sold it like um a couple years
ago uh luckily right before the pandemic
you know perfect timing right so and I
feel bad and I feel good you know what
I'm saying at the same time but um you
should feel good I feel good but I mean
my you know the guys that that that I
bought it from me you know they they had
the big bike sharing you know platform
and they still do and they do a lot of
things
um in Canada with the business Luke
share but
um you know right at the pandemic it
just kind of It kind of took a little
bit of a turn for bike sharing
um and I was always in the retail for
the bike so yeah because you had the
bikes in like Saks Fifth Avenue
Nordstrom Adam and Neiman Marcus MCM
stores I had them on all the uh players
all the football teams all the stars I
mean it was it was pretty massive how we
marketed and promoted it so it was a
good run for us and um
it's out there you know for me I'll be
like I try to stay away from like like
um because I'm trying to watch your
pockets that's all yeah right I like I
mean [__] you know for me
um I just always been low-key
um but it's online but even all kind of
like all my successes in business is
kind of tucked away you know I'm saying
I like put in a lot of work but a lot of
people don't really see it
um it's probably overshadowed just by
the character and the reality shows and
stuff so
um it's all good for me but it was it
was a [__] hell of a deal I told you
that much